this was a massive move for me and I'm
sure some of you out there who know
wrestling you know who land storm is so
this was a big deal I paid for it in
full it was going to be a full camp
where I got room and board but it was
also going to be somewhere I could work
House shows and network which was the
real reason I wanted to do it I needed
to find people who were in the industry
that actually knew what they were doing
and I didn't have a clue what I was
doing but in essence my goal was just to
get a contract with the WWE to get a
tryout I booked my flight and everything
and in preparation for this jump
overseas I started working some local
House shows in my surrounding area and
that's the footage you're seeing now
most likely and then there's murky Fitz
it was honestly the most fun I'd ever
had in my entire life and the good times
didn't stop there right before I was to
leave I even got to sit in and train
with Finn Balor who was right about to
jump into his NXT stand so this was
before he was in WWE this was when he
was Prince debt he's a really cool guy
this however would be the last good
thing that would come my way wrestling
related that I would ever do